OPERATOR: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional material from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right, so today
we're returning to
simulations.
And I'm going to do at first, a
little bit more abstractly,
and then come back
to some details.
So they're different ways to
classify simulation models.
The first is whether it's
stochastic or deterministic.
And the difference here is in
a deterministic simulation,
you should get the same result
every time you run it.
And there's a lot of uses we'll
see for deterministic
simulations.
And then there's stochastic
simulations, where the answer
will differ from run to run
because there's an element of
randomness in it.
So here if you run it again
and again you get the same
outcome every time,
here you may not.
So, for example, the problem
set that's due today -- is
that a stochastic or
deterministic simulation?
Somebody?
Stochastic, exactly.
And that's what we're going
to focus on in this class,
because one of the interesting
questions we'll see about
stochastic simulations is, how
often do have to run them
before you believe the answer?
And that turns out to be
a very important issue.
You run it once, you get
an answer, you can't
take it to the bank.
Because the next time you run
it, you may get a completely
different answer.
So that will get us a little
bit into the whole issue of
statistical analysis.
Another interesting dichotomy
is static vs dynamic.
We'll look at both, but
will spend more
time on dynamic models.
So the issue -- it's
not my phone.
If it's your mother, you could
feel free to take it,
otherwise --
OK, no problem.
Inevitable.
In a dynamic situation,
time plays a role.
And you look at how things
evolve over time.
In a static simulation, there
is no issue with time.
We'll be looking at both, but
most of the time we'll be
focusing on dynamic ones.
So an example of this kind of
thing would be a queuing
network model.
This is one of the most popular
and important kinds of
dynamic simulations.
Where you try and look at how
queues, a fancy word for
lines, evolve over time.
So for example, people who are
trying to decide how many
lanes should be in a highway,
or how far apart the exits
should be, or what should the
ratio of Fast Lane tolls to
manually staffed tolls
should be.
All use queuing networks to try
and answer that question.
And we'll look at some examples
of these later
because they are
very important.
Particularly for things
related to
scheduling and planning.
A third dichotomy is discrete
vs continuous.
Imagine, for example, trying to
analyze the flow of traffic
along the highway.
One way to do it, is to try and
have a simulation which
models each vehicle.
That would be a discrete
simulation, because you've got
different parts.
Alternatively, you might decide
to treat traffic as a
flow, kind of like water flowing
through things, where
changes in the flow can
be described by
differential equations.
That would lead to a
continuous model.
Another example is, a lot of
effort has gone into analyzing
the way blood flows through
the human body.
You can try and model it
discretely, where you take
each red blood cell, each white
blood cell, and look at
how they move, or simulate
how they move.
Or you could treat it
continuously and say, well,
we're just going to treat blood
as a fluid, not made up
of discrete components, and
write some equations to model
how that fluid goes through
and then simulate that.
In this course, we're going to
be focusing mostly on discrete
simulations.
Now if we think about the random
walk we looked at,
indeed it was stochastic,
dynamic, and discrete.
The random walk was an example
of what's called a Monte Carlo
simulation.
This term was coined there.
Anyone know what that is?
Anyone want to guess?
It's the casino, in Monaco,
in Monte Carlo.
It was at one time, before there
was even a Las Vegas,
the most famous casino in
the world certainly.
Still one of the more opulent
ones as you can see.
And unlike Las Vegas, it's real
opulence, as opposed to
faux opulence.
And this term Monte Carlo
simulation, was coined by Ulam
and Metropolis, two
mathematicians, back in 1949,
in reference to the fact that at
Monte Carlos, people bet on
roulette wheels, and cards on
a table, games of chance,
where there was randomness, and
things are discrete, in
some sense.
And they decided, well, this is
just like gambling, and so
they called them Monte
Carlos simulations.
What Is it that makes
this approach work?
And, in some sense, I won't go
into a lot of the math, but I
would like to get some
concepts across.
This is an application of what
are called inferential
statistics.
You have some sample size, some
number of points, and
from that you try to infer
something more general.
We always depend upon one
property when we do this.
And that property is that, a
randomly chosen sample tends
to exhibit the same properties
as the population from which
it is drawn.
So you take a population of
anything, red balls and black
balls, or students, or steps,
and at random draw some
sample, and you assume that
that sample has properties
similar to the entire
population.
So if I were to go around this
room and choose some random
sample of you guys and write
down your hair color, we would
be assuming that the fraction
of you with blonde hair in
that sample would be the same
as the fraction of you with
blonde hair in the
whole class.
That's kind of what
this means.
And the same would be true of
black hair, auburn hair, etc.
So consider, for example,
flipping a coin.
And if I were to flip it some
number of times, say 100
times, you might be able to,
from the proportion of heads
and tails, be able to
infer whether or not
the coin was fair.
That is to say, half the times
it would be heads, in half the
times it would be that tails, or
whether it was unfair, that
it was somehow weighted, so that
heads would come up more
than tails.
And you might say if we did this
100 times and looked at
the results, then we could make
a decision about what
would happen in general when
we looked at the coin.
So let's look in an example
of doing that.
So I wrote a little program,
it's on your
handout, to flip a coin.
So this looks like
the simulations
we looked at before.
I've got flip trials, which says
that the number of heads
and tails is 0 for
i in x range.
What is x range?
So normally you would have
written, for i in range zero
to num flips.
What range does, is it creates a
list, in this case from 0 to
99 and goes through the
list of one at a time.
That's fine, but supposed num
flips were a billion.
Well, range would create
a list with a
billion numbers in it.
Which would take a lot of
space in the computer.
And it's kind of wasted.
What x range says is, don't
bother creating the list just
go through the, in this case,
the numbers one at a time.
So it's much more efficient
than range.
It will behave the same way as
far as the answers you get,
but it doesn't use
as much space.
And since some of the
simulations we'll be doing
will have lots of trials, or
lots of flips, it's worth the
trouble to use x range
instead of range.
Yeah?
Pardon?
STUDENT: Like, why would
we ever use range
instead of x range?
PROFESSOR: No good reason, when
dealing with numbers,
unless you wanted to do
something different with the
list. But, there's
no good reason.
The right answer for
the purposes of
today is, no good reason.
I typically use x range
all the time if I'm
thinking about it.
It was just something that
didn't seem worth introducing
earlier in this semester.
But good question.
Certainly deserving of
a piece of candy.
All right, so for i in x range,
coin is equal some
random integer 0 or 1.
If coin is equal to 0 then
heads, else tails.
Well, that's pretty easy.
And then all I'm going to do
here is go through and flip it
a bunch of times, and
we'll get some
answer, and do some plots.
So let's look at an example.
We'll try -- we'll flip 100
coins, we'll do 100 trials and
see what we get.
Error in multi-line statement.
All right, what have
I done wrong here?
Obviously did something by
accident, edited something I
did not intend edit.
Anyone spot what I did wrong?
Pardon?
The parentheses.
I typed where I didn't intend.
Which line?
Down at the bottom?
Obviously my, here, yes,
I deleted that.
Thank you.
All right, so we have a couple
of figures here.
Figure one, I'm showing
a histogram.
The number of trials on the
y-axis and the difference
between heads and tails , do
I have more of one than the
other on the x-axis.
And so we what we could see
out of my 100 trials,
somewhere around 22 of them
came out the same,
close to the same.
But way over here we've
got some funny ones.
100 and there was a
difference of 25.
Pretty big difference.
Another way to look at the same
data, and I'm doing this
just to show that there are
different ways of looking at
data, is here, what I've plotted
is each trial, the
percent difference.
So out of 100 flips.
And this is normalizing it,
because if I flip a million
coins, I might expect the
difference to be pretty big in
absolute terms, but maybe
very small as a
percentage of a million.
And so here, we can again see
that as these stochastic kinds
of things, there's a pretty
big difference, right?
We've got one where it was over
25 percent, and several
where it's zero.
So the point here, we can see
from this graph, that if I'd
done only one trial and just
assumed that was the answer as
to whether my coin was weighted
or not, I could
really have fooled myself.
So the the main point is that
you need to be careful when
you're doing these
kinds of things.
And this green line
here is the mean.
So it says on average, the
difference was seven precent.
Well suppose, maybe, instead
of, flipping 100, I were to
flip 1,000.
Well, doesn't seem to
want to notice it.
One more try and then I'll
just restart it, which is
always the safest thing as
we've discussed before.
Well, we won't panic.
Sometimes this helps.
If not, here we go.
So let's say we wanted
to flip 1,000 coins.
So now what do we think?
Is the difference going to be
bigger or smaller than when we
flipped 100?
Is the average difference
between heads and tails bigger
or smaller with 1,000 flips
than with 100 flips?
Well, the percentage will be
smaller, but in absolute
terms, it's probably going
to be bigger, right?
Because I've got more
chances to stray.
But we'll find out.
So here we see that the mean
difference is somewhere in the
twenties, which was much
higher than the mean
difference for 100 flips.
On the other hand, if we look at
the percentage, we see it's
much lower.
Instead of seven percent, it's
around two and a half percent
in the main.
There's something else
interesting to observe in
figure two, relative to when we
looked at with 100 flips.
What else is pretty interesting
about the
difference between these two
figures, if you can remember
the other one?
Yeah?
STUDENT: There are no zeros?
PROFESSOR: There are no zeros.
That's right, as it happens
there were no zeros.
Not so surprising that it
didn't ever come out
exactly 500, 500.
What else?
What was the biggest difference,
percentage-wise,
we saw last time?
Over 25.
So notice how much narrower
the range is here.
Instead of ranging from 2 to 25
or something like that, it
ranges from 0 to 7, or
maybe 7 and a little.
So, by flipping more coins, the
experiment becomes more
reproduce-able.
I'm looks like the same because
of scaling, but in
fact the range is
much narrower.
Each experiment tends to give
an answer closer to all the
other experiments.
That's a good thing.
It should give you confidence
that the answers are getting
pretty close to right.
That they're not bouncing
all over the place.
And if I were to flip a million
coins, we would find
the range would get
very tight.
So notice that even though
there's similar information in
the histogram and the plot,
different things leap out at
you, as you look at it.
All right, we could ask a lot of
other interesting questions
about coins here.
But, we'll come back to this in
a minute and look at some
other questions.
I want to talk again a little
bit more generally.
It's kind of easy to think about
running a simulation to
predict the future.
So in some sense, we look at
this, and this predicts what
might happen if I flipped
1,000 coins.
That the most likely event
would be that I'd have
something under 10 in the
difference between heads and
tails, but that it's not
terribly unlikely that I might
have close to 70 as
a difference.
And if I ran more than 100
trials I'd see more, but this
helps me predict what
might happen.
Now we don't always use
simulations to predict what
might happen.
We sometimes actually use
simulations to understand the
current state of the world.
So for example, if I told you
that we are going to flip
three coins, and I wanted you
to predict the probability
that all three would be
either heads, or all
three would be tails.
Well, if you'd studied any
probability, you could know
how to do that.
If you hadn't studied
probability, you would say,
well, that's OK, we have a
simulation right here.
Let's just do it.
Here we go again.
And so let's try it.
Let's flip three coins, and
let's do it 4,000 times here.
Well, that's kind
of hard to read.
It's pretty dense.
But we can see that the
mean here is 50.
And, this is a little
easier to read.
This tells us that, how many
times will the difference,
right, be zero 3,000
out of 4,000.
Is that right?
What do you think?
Do you believe this?
Have I done the right thing?
three coins, 4,000 flips, how
often should they all be heads,
or how often should
they all be tails?
What does this tell us?
It tells us one-fourth of the
time they'll all be-- the
difference between, wait a
minute, how can the difference
between -- something's wrong
with my code, right?
Because I only have two
possible values.
I hadn't expected this.
I obviously messed
something up.
Pardon?
STUDENT: It's right.
PROFESSOR: It's right,
because?
STUDENT: Because you had an odd
number of flips, and when
you split them --
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
STUDENT: When you split
an odd number --
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So it is correct.
And it gives us what we want.
But now, let's think about
a different situation.
Anybody got a coin here?
Anyone give me three coins?
I can trust somebody, I hope.
What a cheap -- anybody got
silver dollars, would be
preferable?
All right, look at this.
She's very carefully given
me three pennies.
She had big, big money in that
purse, too, but she didn't
want me to have it.
All right, so I'm going to
take these three pennies,
jiggle them up, and now ask you,
what's the probability
that all three of
them are heads?
Anyone want to tell me?
It's either 0 or 1, right?
And I can actually look
at you and tell you
exactly which it is.
And you can't see which it is.
So, how should you think about
what the probability it?
Well, you might as well assume
that it's whatever this graph
tells you it is.
Because the fact that you
don't have access to the
information, means that you
really might as well treat the
present as if it's the future.
That it's unknown.
And so in fact we frequently,
when there's data out there
that we don't have access to,
we use simulations and
probabilities to estimate, make
our best guess, about the
current state of the world.
And so, in fact, guessing the
value of the current state, is
really no different from
predicting the value of a
future state when you don't
have the information.
In general, all right, now,
just to show that your
precautions were unnecessary.
Where was I?
Right.
In general, when we're trying
to predict the future, or in
this case, guess the present, we
have to use information we
already have to make our
prediction or our best guess.
So to do that, we have to always
ask the question, is
past behavior a good prediction
of future behavior?
So if I flip a coin 1,000 times
and count up the heads
and tails, is that a good
prediction what will happen
the next time?
This is a step people often
omit, in doing these
predictions.
See the recent meltdown of
the financial system.
Where people had lots of
stochastic simulations
predicting what the market would
do, and they were all
wrong, because they were all
based upon assuming samples
drawn from the past would
predict the future.
So, as we build these models,
that's the question you always
have to ask yourself.
Is, in some sense, this true?
Because usually what we're doing
is, we're choosing a
random sample from the
past and hoping it
predicts the future.
And that is to say, is the
population we have available
the same has the one
in the future.
So it's easy to see how one
might use these kinds of
simulations to figure out things
that are inherently
stochastic.
So for example, to predict
a poker hand.
What's the probability of my
getting a full house when I
draw this card from the deck?
To predict the probability of
coming up with a particular
kind of poker hand.
Is a full house more probable
than a straight?
Or not?
Well, you can deal out lots of
cards, and count them up, just
as Ulam suggested
for Solitaire.
And that's often what we do.
Interestingly enough though,
we can use randomized
techniques to get solutions
to problems that are not
inherently stochastic.
And that's what I
want to do now.
So, consider for example, pi.
Many of you have probably
heard of this.
For thousands of years,
literally, people have known
that there is a constant, pi,
associated with circles such
that pi times the radius squared
equals the area.
And they've known that pi times
the diameter is equal to
the circumference.
So, back in the days of the
Egyptian pharaohs, it was
known that such a constant
existed.
In fact, it didn't acquire
the name pi
until the 18th century.
And so they called it
other things, but
they knew it existed.
And for thousands of years,
people have speculated on what
it's value was.
Sometime around 1650 BC, the
Egyptians said that pi was
3.16, something called
the Rhind Papyrus,
something they found.
Many years later, about
1,000 years later, the
Bible said pi was three.
And I quote, this is describing
the specifications
for the Great Temple of Solomon.
"He made a molten sea
of 10 cubits from brim to brim,
round in compass, and 5
cubit the height thereof, and
a line of 30 cubits did
compass it round about." So, all
right, so what we've got
here is, we've got everything
we need to plug into these
equations and solve for pi,
and it comes out three.
And it does this in more than
one place in the Bible.
I will not comment on the
theological implications of
this assertion.
Sarah Palin might.
And Mike Huckabee
certainly would.
The first theoretical
calculation of pi was carried
out by Archimedes, a great
Greek mathematician from
Syracuse, that was about
somewhere around 250 BC.
And he said that pi was
somewhere between 223 divided
by 71, and 22 divided by 7.
This was amazingly profound.
He knew he didn't know what the
answer was, but he had a
way to give an upper and a lower
bound, and say it was
somewhere between these
two values.
And in fact if you calculate it,
the average of those two
values is 3.1418.
Not bad for the time.
This was not by measurement,
he actually had a very
interesting way of
calculating it.
All right, so this is where it
stood, for years and years,
because of course people forgot
the Rhind Papyrus, and
they forgot Archimedes, and they
believed the Bible, and
so three was used
for a long time.
People sort of knew it wasn't
right, but still.
Then quite interestingly, Buffon
and Laplace, two great
French mathematicians, actually
people had better
estimates using Archimedes'
methods long before they came
along, proposed a way to do
it using a simulation.
Now, since Laplace lived between
1749 and 1827, it was
not a computer simulation.
So I'm going to show you,
basically, the way that he
proposed to do it. the basic
idea was you take a square,
assume that's a square, and you
inscribe in it a quarter
of a circle.
So here, you have the radius
of the square r.
And then you get some person to,
he used needles, but I'm
going to use darts, to throw
darts at the shape.
And some number of the darts
will land in the circle part,
and some number of the darts
will land out here, in the
part of the square that's not
inscribed by the circle.
And then we can look at the
ratio of the darts in the
shaded area divided by
the total number of
darts in the square.
And that's equal to the shaded
area divided by the area of
the square.
The notion being, if they're
landing at random in these
places, the proportion here and
not here will depend upon
the relative areas.
And that certainly
makes sense.
If this were half the area of
the square, then you'd expect
half the darts to
land in here.
And then as you can see in your
handout, a little simple
algebra can take this, plus pi r
squared equals the area, you
can solve for pi, and you can
get that pi is equal to 4, and
I'll write it, h, where h is
the hit ratio, the number
falling in here.
So people sort of see why that
should work intuitively?
And that it's a very clever idea
to use randomness to find
a value that there's nothing
random about.
So we can now do
the experiment.
I need volunteers
to throw darts.
Come on.
Come on up.
I need more volunteers.
I have a lot of darts.
Anybody else?
Anybody?
All right, then since you're
all in the front
row, you get stuck.
So now we'll try it.
And you guys, we'll see how many
of you hit in the circle,
and how many of you hit there.
Go ahead, on the count of
3, everybody throw.
1, 2, 3.
Ohh!
He did that on purpose.
You'll notice Professor Grimson
isn't here today, and
that's because I told him he was
going to have to hold the
dart board.
Well, what we see here is, we
ignore the ones that missed
all together.
And we'll see that, truly,
I'm assuming
these are random throws.
We have one here and two here.
Well, your eyes will tell you
that's the wrong ratio.
Which suggests that having
students throw darts is not
the best way to solve
this problem.
And so you will see in your
handout a computer
simulation of it.
So let's look at that.
So this is find pi.
So at the beginning of this
code, by the way, it's not on
your handout, is some magic.
I got tired of looking at big
numbers without commas
separating the thousands
places.
You've see me in other
lectures counting
the number of zeros.
What we have here is, that just
tells it I have to have
two versions, one for the
Mac, and one for the PC.
To set some variables that had
to write integers, things in
general, and I'm saying here, do
it the way you would do it
in the United States
in English.
And UTF8 is just an extended
character code.
Anyway, you don't need to learn
anything about this
magic, but it's just a handy
little way to make the numbers
easier to read.
All right, so let's let's
try and look at it.
There's not much interesting
to see here.
I've done this little thing,
format ints, that uses this
magic to say grouping equals
true, that means put a comma
in the thousand places.
But again, you can
ignore all that.
The interesting part, is that
from Pylab I import star,
import random in math.
As some of you observed, the
order these imports matters.
I think I sent out an email
yesterday explaining what was
going on here.
This was one of the things
that I knew, and probably
should've mentioned.
But since I knew it, I thought
everyone knew.
Silly me.
It was of course a dumb
thing to think.
And then I'm going to throw
a bunch of darts.
The other thing you'll notice
is, throw darts has a
parameter called should plot.
And that's because when I
throw a billion darts, I
really don't want to try and
take the time to plot a
billion points.
So let's first look at
a little example.
We'll try throwing
10,000 darts.
And it gives me an estimated
value of pi of 3.16.
And what we'll see here, is
that the number of darts
thrown, the estimate
changes, right?
When I threw one dart, the
estimate of pi was 4.
I threw my second dart, it
dropped all the way to 3.
And then it bounced around a
while, and then at the end, it
starts to really stabilize
around the true value.
You'll notice, by the way, that
what I've got here is a
logarithmic x-axis.
If you look at the code, you'll
see I've told it to be
semi log x.
And that's because I wanted you
to be able to see what was
happening early on, where
it was fluctuating.
But out here it's kind of
boring, because the
fluctuations are so small.
So that was a good
way to do it.
All right now.
Do I think I have enough
samples here?
Well, I don't want you to cheat
and look at the estimate
and say no, you don't, because
you know that's
not the right answer.
And, it's not even as good
as Archimedes did.
But how could you sort of look
at the data, and get a sense
that maybe this is not
the right answer?
Well, even at the end, if we
look at it, it's still
wiggling around a fair amount.
We can zoom in.
And it's bouncing up
and down here.
I'm in a region, but it's sort
of makes us think that maybe
it hasn't stabilized, right?
You'd like it to not be
moving very much.
Now, by the way, the other thing
we could've looked at,
when we ran it, let's run
it again, probably get a
different answer by the way.
Yeah, notice the different
answer here.
Turns out to be a better answer,
but it's just an
accident, right?
Notice in the beginning it
fluctuates wildly, and it
fluctuates less wildly
at the end.
Why is that?
And don't just say because
it's close to right
and it knows it.
Why do the mathematics of this,
in some sense, tell us
it has to fluctuate less
wildly at the end?
Yes?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Exactly,
exactly right.
If I've only thrown two darts,
the third dart can have a big
difference in the
average value.
But if I've thrown a million
darts, the million and first
can't matter very much.
And what this tells me is, as
I want ever more digits of
precision, I have to run a lot
more trials to get there.
And that's often true, that
simulations can get you in the
neighborhood quickly, but the
more precision you want, the
number of steps grows
quite quickly.
Now, the fact that I got such
different answers the two
times I ran this suggests
strongly that I shouldn't
believe either answer.
Right?
So we need to do
something else.
So let's try something else.
Let's try throwing a lot
more darts here,
and see what we get.
Now if you look at my code,
you'll see I'm printing
intermediate values.
Every million darts, I'm
printing the value.
And I did that because the first
time I ran this on a big
number, I was afraid I had an
infinite loop and my program
was not working.
So I just said, all right, let's
put a print statement in
the loop, so I could see that
it's making progress.
And then I decided it was just
kind of nice to look at it, to
see what was going on here.
So now you see that if I throw
10 million darts, I'm starting
to get a much better estimate.
You'll also see, as predicted,
that as I get further out, the
value of the estimate changes
less and less with each
million new darts, because it's
a smaller fraction of the
total darts.
But it's getting a lot better.
Still not quite there.
Let's just see what happens,
I can throw in another one.
This is going to take
a little while.
So I can talk while
it's running.
Oops, what did I do here?
So, it's going to keep on going
and going and going.
And then if we were to run it
with this number of darts
several times over, we would
discover that we got answers
that were very, very similar.
From that we can take comfort,
statistically, that we're
really getting close to the
same answer every time, so
we've probably thrown enough
darts to feel comfortable that
we're doing what's statistically
the right thing.
And that there maybe isn't
a lot of point in
throwing more darts.
Does that mean that we have
the right answer?
No, not necessarily, and that's
what we're going to
look at next week.